>>Choir: [singing]
>>Narrator: Brookfield High
School in Canada's Capital City
of Ottawa, is a study in diversity.
>>Anne: If you were to walk the
halls of Brookfield High School,
you see a real kaleidoscope,
colors, cultures, religions,
and 45 to 50 different languages.
>>Narrator: In 2004, the school
received a technology grant
that provided 23 laptop computers,
wireless internet access,
and teacher training.
>>Beverly: Or you go to File, New,
then we can just make a new one.
>>Narrator: The new technology
has opened new worlds to students,
from global video conferences--
>>Teacher: Okay, we have
another question, Mr. Davis.
>>Student: Just drop the
ball and let it bounce.
>>Narrator: to the
exploration of invisible forces.
>>Student: So there you can
see where the ball bounced,
and then it's constant velocity.
>>Anne: The teachers that have
been connected with the grant,
have really used the technology
to consider how they teach.
They plan their lessons,
knowing, of course,
that they've got the
technology, and therefore,
they're far more creative
in their teaching.
>>Beverly: Okay, so you're
going to be going to the site
with the tablets, and you're
going to be doing a little bit
of research about the Rideau River.
>>Narrator: Four times a year,
science teacher Beverly Wilkinson
takes her biology class on the road
to collect data on plant and animal
species in Ottawa's Rideau River.
>>Beverly: Try to get one organism
at a time, and organize them
into the white egg cartons.
>>When you're entering the data
onsite, it makes it more real.
If you wait a day or two, then
they forget, and it separates
from the actual science
that they are doing.
So it's all part of the process.
And they will use the tools that
we have in order to record all
of their data onsite, so it's like
they're acting as true scientists.
>>Narrator: Students post their data
to Ottawa's Museum of Nature Website,
where it can be shared with
students all over Canada,
who are doing similar studies.
>>Katja: There's a youth
portal that they can go to,
and they can input the data that
they found from this project,
so different types of, you know,
measurements about the water,
the types of invertebrates
that they found.
>>Student: That's our main specimen.
>>Katja: And so this information
is accessible to anybody
who has access to the web.
They can take a look at
the data that's collected,
and compare it to their own rivers.
>>Teacher: For you,
Monsieur, delivery.
>>Gordon: Delivery.
Thank you.
>>Narrator: The tablet PCs move from
classroom to classroom in a cart
that includes a wireless hub.
>>Gordon: Galileo, what
was Galileo's experiment?
Five hundred years ago, they said,
who's going to hit the
ground first, 500 years ago--
>>Narrator: Students in Gordon
Kubanek's physics class use the
computers to visualize
the intangible.
>>Gordon: There's much, much less
mass in all that there, right?
>>Physics is, sometimes you can't
do an experiment physically,
so what you do is, you do the
experiment in your imagination,
and it adds this element of what
we call, spatial intelligence,
so when most people think about
physics, they think about math,
which is true, but actually,
math alone is insufficient.
You have to be able to
visualize these interactions
in three dimensions, because
there's real things happening
and so the technology
allows you to do that,
and you could never do it before.
>>We know that you have a
certain weight at the surface,
which he's drawn over here.
And if you weigh nothing
in the middle,
halfway, you should weigh half.
It's logical, yeah?
And by the way, the diagram helps.
>> In the simulation, they would
change the gravitational field,
Earth, Moon, Jupiter,
and see the effect.
The simulation would graph it, you
could accelerate different objects
to see, as you accelerated them,
what would their motion look like?
What would the graph look like?
And it visualized the ideas.
>>Narrator: The technology
helps students learn,
by explaining their work to others.
>>Student: So if you're
one there, and zero there--
>>Gordon: Yeah.
>>Student: You can't be half.
>>Gordon: Research tell us,
whoever does the explanation does the
most learning, so in most classrooms,
teachers are learning a lot,
because they're talking a lot,
and the kids really aren't.
so you want to try to discourage
the memorization kind of approach,
want the kids explaining
things and showing their work.
The teacher wandering
around much more,
being more on the side guiding them.
>>Do you weigh less, compared
to being at the surface?
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Gordon: Okay, that's good.
>>Student: Wait--
>>Gordon: It does take
a lot more time
to design a good lesson
with technology.
When you have a normal lesson,
you can literally think about it
for maybe 10 or 15 minutes,
get your resources together,
and you're good to go.
With technology, you have to make
a real lesson that's designed
for everything, so the
students know what to do next,
and that takes, like, an hour.
So that's the downside,
if there is any.
>>Anne: I am blessed with a staff
who's willing to take some risks,
and to come into my office and
say, should we give this a try?
And there's not a lot more that
I can ask for as a principal.
We're hoping that each department,
whether it be in an art classroom,
an English classroom, social
science, phys ed, health,
we'll sort of have a technology
person who the other teachers can go
to and get some creative ideas from.
>>Jeannie: Okay, so do I get to
this program through the file menu?
>>I don't pretend to be an expert,
but I'm very good at asking for help,
and I can see the possibilities
that technology opens up,
even when I don't know
how to make that work yet.
>>Narrator: When Jeannie
Hunter needs help,
she turns to colleague,
Bev Wilkinson.
>>Jeannie: Working with Bev has been
a real asset, because she's able
to take the crazy ideas that I have
and structure them and make them work
in a way that I can use them.
So she gives me a level
of accessibility
that I wouldn't have otherwise,
and makes it accessible
to the students as well.
>>Narrator: Last year, the World
Voices Choir, released its first CD,
and made it available
over the internet.
>>Choir: [singing]
>>Michael: All of a
sudden, it hits home,
people pretty much anywhere in
the world can begin to connect,
so I mean, we could reach to
Africa, we could reach to Sudan,
and we could reach to China,
You know, people could
start, you know, connecting,
getting past the language
barrier, getting past,
you know, the distance barrier.
>>Choir: [singing]
>>Jeannie: We had someone
e-mail from Kenya, and say,
I'm listening to your CD, and he
wrote the e-mail in Kiswahili.
I couldn't read it.
So I have two Kenyan girls in my
choir, and I sat down with them,
and I said, I'd like to
show you this e-mail.
And for them, the moment where they
could read that e-mail, and go, wow,
somebody from home
is listening to us.
The world becomes a very small
place when you're able to interact
with people from anywhere.
>>Choir: [singing]
>>Narrator: For more
information about,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.